[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous rien
n'est figé mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le barrage de la
renaissance sur le nil bleu ce méga
projet hydroélectrique de l'ethiopie est
devenu en quelques années
source de tension entre ce pays et ses
deux voisins le soudan et l'egypte alors
comment les trois acteurs se disputent
il les eaux du nil le nouveau tour des
négociation n'aboutit à rien en janvier
l'ethiopie le soudan et l'egypte échoué
à se mettre d'accord sur la gestion du
grand projet éthiopien
aucun consensus n'est trouvé sur la
durée du remplissage du réservoir ni sur
le débit minimum garanti de sujets clés
qui font débat afin de débloquer la
situation plusieurs états et
organisations internationales se propose
comme médiateur en 2019
washington ne réussit pas à rapprocher
la position des trois pays
les négociations sous l'égide de l'union
africaine ce seul elle aussi par un
échec parce que le dialogue piétine
l'egypte laisse entendre qu'il n'exclut
pas la solution militaire et l'huile sur
le feu et jeté par le différend
frontalier entre le soudan et les tubes
depuis fin 2020 les affrontements ont
fait plusieurs morts
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur ce barrage au coeur des
tensions entre l'egypte le soudan et
l'ethiopie
c'est le blitz long de 1,8 km est au 245
m le chantier du grand barrage de la
renaissance est lancée en 2011
la centrale hydroélectrique adjointe
sera la plus puissante d'afrique située
en amont sur le nil bleu elle devrait
avoir une capacité de production de plus
de 6000 mégawatts et le réservoir du
barrage pourrait stocker plus de 70
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau le coût
de ce projet gigantesque s'élève à près
de 5 milliards de dollars une somme
entièrement payée par l'ethiopie la
centrale hydro électrique permettra donc
de combler les manques nationaux en
électricité
la majorité de la population éthiopienne
n'y a toujours pas accès pourtant avec
la mise en oeuvre de ce barrage
addis abeba aurait suffisamment
d'électricité pour même en exporter dans
le reste de la région
un commerce représentant des centaines
de millions de dollars par an qui
pourrait renflouer les caisses de l'état
une aubaine financière et énergétique
pour addis abeba surtout ce projet
pourtant vu d'un mauvais oeil par les
deux états un aval du nil le soudan et
l'egypte les deux craignent que la
montée en charge du barrage n'entraîne
une réduction du débit du fleuve du nil
bleu et conséquences pourraient s'avérer
désastreuses sécheresse faibles récoltes
disparition de poissons afin une
réduction de la production d'électricité
un vrai barrage aux négociations entre
l'ethiopie le soudan et l'egypte le
grand barrage de la renaissance se
prépare pour la seconde phase du
remplissage de son gigantesque réservoir
addis abeba compte effectuer l'opération
en juillet prochain malgré les
protestations du caire et de khartoum
qui craignent une réduction du débit du
fleuve du nil bleu toutes les tentatives
d'élaborer un accord finisse par un
échec
les etats unis qui parraine le dialogue
depuis déjà deux ans sont accusés par
l'ethiopie d'avoir une position biaisé
l'union africaine elle non plus ne
réussit pas à négocier un consensus
la russie et les émirats arabes unis
voudraient essayer réconcilier les
parties mais leur médiation
n'est pas sûr d'être accepté la
situation se complexifie par des menaces
mutuelles l'egypte évoque un danger pour
la paix régionale en cas d'actions
unilatérales de l'ethiopie mais addis
abeba se dit être prête à défendre le
barrage par la force
quant aux relations soudano éthiopienne
elles se sont dégradées suite à des
affrontements frontaliers entre les deux
états quels sont les enjeux et les
risques dans ces disputes autour des
eaux du nil
pourquoi les négociations autour de ce
barrage sont elles au point mort comment
ce problème
peut-il jouer sur la stabilité régionale
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
nous rejoignons francs galant
professionnels du secteur de l'eau et
chercheur associé à la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique monsieur galant
bonjour bonjour monsieur
pourquoi selon vous les négociations sur
le barrage échoue telle à chaque fois
qu'elle parti y fait barrage
alors effectivement depuis la pose de la
première pierre de ce barrage en 2011
par feu le premier ministre mélès zenawi
premier ministre éthiopien
alors que les rues du caire était en
ébullition et demandé la destitution du
président moubarak
un certain nombre de négociations ont eu
lieu à partir de 2015
suite notamment à cette rencontre
historique qui avait vu le premier
ministre éthiopien de l'époque le
président sisi président égyptien et le
président soudanais est barrée omar el
béchir main dans la main pour
effectivement trouver une solution
politique et technique à l'avancé de cet
ouvrage est depuis 2015 la question qui
se pose c'est
celle du remplissage de ce barrage et
c'est là que les discussions les
négociations patinent alors
effectivement de part et d'autres les
accusent de noms avancés sur ce sur ce
projet dans les faits effectivement il
est reproché à l'ethiopie de faire
barrage aux avancées égyptienne puisque
l'egypte a proposé un projet de
résolution devant le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies un projet qui a été
supportée par le soudan mais toujours
pas d'accord pensez vous que la mise en
oeuvre du barrage accordera à l'ethiopie
plus de poids géopolitique dans la
région et que ce soit aussi la raison de
l'indignation égyptienne alors il est
clair que l'ethiopie avec ce barrage va
devenir hydro dominant comme un certain
nombre de pays le sont dans le monde par
exemple la turquie sur la mésopotamie il
est très clair que l'ethiopie avec ce
barrage souhaitent rentrer dans la
modernité
vous savez l'ethiopie a connu ces
dernières années un taux de croissance
de 7 8% par an sa position est tout à
fait défendable
elle veut peser économiquement
régionalement diplomatiquement et ce
barrage va nous permettre effectivement
de remplir ses objectifs de grande
nation est possible que cette volonté
éthiopienne inquiète
l'egypte qui est traditionnement
reconnue comme la puissance régionale
mais je pense qu' il serait ce serait
mal connaître entre guillemets la
position égyptienne qui est aujourd'hui
sur ce dossier une position de sécurité
nationale l'egypte sans une épée de
damoclès définitivement maintenant posé
sur sa tête et ne peut se permettre une
baisse du débit du nil
compte tenu de ces enjeux économiques
agricoles
rappelons que 94 % de l'eau utilisée en
egypte a une vocation agricole et je
vais ajouter en cela avant de terminer
mon propos
la question qui se pose fondamentalement
c'est la question de la bombe
démographique il ya un an environ à la
même époque
l'egypte a dépassé le cap de 100
millions d'individus et ce chiffre n'est
pas prêt de s'arrêter puisque
aujourd'hui vous avez 60 % de la
population égyptienne qui a moins de 30
ans et un taux de fécondité par femme
qui est 3,6 et est donc cette insécurité
démographique si je puis dire placer au
rang de priorité nationale se double
d'une insécurité alimentaire parce qu'il
faut nourrir cette population et est
surtout un fait nouveau d'une insécurité
hydrique avec la construction de ce
barrage
alors si vous rajoutez à cela le
changement climatique qui a aussi son
n'a pas comme dans n'importe quel pays
avec une baisse de pluviométrie avec d
évaporation de plus en plus forte
là vous comprenez ou plus en plus la
position égyptienne qui véritablement
fait de cette situation de progression
du barrage sur le nil bleu en territoire
éthiopien un casus belli
merci beaucoup monsieur galant nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin d'émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore au fur et à mesure que la mise en
oeuvre du projet approche l'egypte et le
soudan se sont de plus en plus menacée
selon eux le barrage éthiopien de la
renaissance est une entrave direct pour
leurs intérêts nationaux
si l'ethiopie continue à remplir le
barrage de la renaissance en juillet
prochain
cela constituera une menace directe pour
notre sécurité nationale
je tiens à souligner qu'il s'agit du
dossier le plus important pour toutes
les autorités de l'état en egypte à
l'heure actuelle la voie vers
l'apaisement passe par la conclusion
d'un accord légalement contraignant avec
les tupi sur la gestion de ce barrage
les négociations se poursuivent depuis
sans résultat la dernière tentative date
de janvier 2021
elles se soldent elle aussi par un échec
en cause les divergences sur le format
de travail
le soudan insiste pour que l'élaboration
de l'accord soit confiée aux experts de
l'union africaine
l'egypte et l'ethiopie prône pour les
négociations trilatérale
cependant le vrai problème est le
remplissage du réservoir côté éthiopien
car de lui dépend la vie des voisins de
l'étude
sa capacité totale est de 74 milliards
de mètres cubes d'eau alors que le débit
annuel total du nil bleu est de 49
milliards de mètres cubes par an
théoriquement le remplissage le plus
rapide du barrage exigerait l'arrêt
total du cours du nil bleu pour un an et
demi or l'ethiopie compte achever cette
opération en cinq ou sept ans l'egypte
lui voudrait rallonger ce délai sur 12
ans minimum de plus le caire exige
d'addis-abeba de maintenir le débit du
nil d'au moins 41 milliards de mètres
cubes par an l'ethiopie refusent de
s'engager sur un tel chiffre mais laisse
entendre qu'elle pourrait accorder 30
milliards de mètres cubes par an quand m
parmi les exigences soudanaise la mise
en place d'un mécanisme de coordination
du remplissage et celui de l' échange de
données ici un compromis serait possible
en janvier les autorités éthiopiennes
déclare avoir fait les premiers pas afin
de répondre aux préoccupations du soudan
en revanche l'ethiopie rejette la
principale demande de l'egypte et du
soudan ne pas commencer le remplissage
du réservoir avant que l'accord ne soit
conclu le gouvernement éthiopien annonce
en juillet 2020 que la première phase du
remplissage de ce barrage géant est déjà
accomplie en pratique cela signifie qu
environ 5 milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau se sont déjà accumulés
dans le réservoir ce volume permettrait
de tester deux premières turbines sur 16
au total les autorités éthiopiennes
rassure l'opération n'aurait pas
d'impact significatif sur le niveau
d'eau dans le nil car elle se fait sous
l'effet de fortes précipitations et non
pas grâce au retrait de l'eau du fleuve
le soudan ne semble pas être convaincu
il ressort du débit mesuré au poste
frontière d'al daïn avec l'ethiopie qui
lie à une baisse du niveau d'eau est
égal à 90 millions de mètres cubes par
jour et addis abeba ne s'arrête pas là
lors du dernier tour des négociations en
janvier la délégation éthiopienne
prévient que la seconde phase du
remplissage débutera cette année peu
importe la conclusion ou non de l'accord
le caire et khartoum
il voit une menace directe pour leur
pays quant au soudan il craint que le
remplissage du barrage éthiopien affecte
le fonctionnement de ces deux barrages
hydroélectriques les rosaires et de
sénart la pêche et l'agriculture serait
aussi endommagé mais moins qu'en egypte
qui dépend totalement de l'eau du lit
pour les officiels égyptiens le
remplissage du barrage par les
éthiopiens peut causer une véritable
catastrophe dans le secteur agricole
près de trente mille kilomètres carrés
des terres seraient affectés par
l'absence d'irrigation est la sécheresse
plus de la moitié des pêcheries serait
fermé la population égyptienne qui vit à
plus de 90% dans les régions proches des
berges ferait face à une réduction
drastique de ses approvisionnements en
eau enfin la production d'électricité
pourraient aussi chuté et le barrage
égyptien d'assouan verrez une réduction
importante du niveau d'eau le dialogue
fait du surplace et la presse égyptienne
évoque de plus en plus souvent la
possibilité d'un conflit ouvert entre
l'ethiopie et l'egypte les autorités
officielles
elles se disent attachés à la diplomatie
pourtant une solution militaire n'est
pas totalement à exclure en mai 2020
suite à la promesse de l'ethiopie de
commencer le remplissage du réservoir le
président égyptien al sisi mais toute
l'armée en état d' alerte
un mois plus tard le ministre égyptien
des affaires étrangères en voit un autre
signal lors de son discours au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu convoqué à son lit
si hâtive il évoque la menace majeure
pour la paix et la stabilité de la
région
en cas de remplissage unilatérale du
barrage est même si le rapport des
forces n'est pas en faveur de l'ethiopie
et le premier ministre éthiopien se dit
prêt à une confrontation militaire avec
l'egypte il convient de souligner
qu'aucune force ne peut empêcher
l'ethiopie de construire un barrage
s'il est nécessaire d'entrer en guerre
nous pourrions mobilisé des millions de
personnes alors pourquoi le compromis
est-il si difficile à trouver qui joue
le rôle de médiateur dans les
pourparlers entre les trois états enfin
quels avantages ce méga projet présente
il pour l'ethiopie la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
l'egypte n'y croyais pas mais l'ethiopie
l'a fait la première phase du
remplissage du barrage est accomplie et
la seconde est en cours de préparation
la situation au pied risque de priver
l'egypte de sa domination qu'elle
exercée sur le nil depuis des siècles
deuxième plus long fleuve mondial après
l'amazone le nil est souvent qualifiée
de berceau de la civilisation
aujourd'hui le fleuve reste une artère
vitale qui alimente en eau douce
onze pays de la région l'un d'entre eux
affiche ses droits historiques sur les
eaux nilotique l'egypte il s'agit non
seulement de siècle de domination
égyptienne sur le nil mais aussi des
traités internationaux qui confirme ce
statut privilégié
le premier est signé en 1929 entre
l'egypte alors sous protectorat
britannique et le royaume uni qui
contrôlait pratiquement tout le bassin
nilotique
le document donne un droit de veto à
l'egypte sur tous les projets
hydrauliques des colonies britanniques
riveraine trente ans plus tard en 1959
l'autre accord de partage du nil voit le
jour cette fois entre l'egypte et le
soudan
ce dernier vient d'obtenir son
indépendance et exige la renégociation
des conditions de l'accord de 1929
résultats l'egypte et le soudan se
répartissent des quotas de prélèvement
sur le nil 66 % du débit annuel pour
l'egypte et 22% pour le soudan dans les
années qui suivent khartoum et le caire
s'autorise à construire chacun un
barrage le barrage des roses ars au
soudan et celui d'assouan en egypte
or dès la fin des années 70 un autre
acteur régional réclame sa part du
gâteau nilotique l'ethiopie c'est elle
qui contribue à 85% au débit du fleuve
mais qui ne l'utilisent quasiment pas
pourtant les projet éthiopien qui
prévoyait la construction d'une série de
barrages sur le nil se heurte à une
farouche opposition de l'egypte qui
menace d'une guerre
il faut donc attendre une trentaine
d'années pour que les choses bougent
avec le début du printemps arabe
l'egypte est embourbé dans un chaos sans
précédent et l'ethiopie en profite
en 2011 le premier ministre éthiopien
mêlés zenawi pose la première pierre du
futur barrage la construction tant
attendu et démarrer
le coût du projet s'élève à près de 5
milliards de dollars la somme est
entièrement versée par l'état via un
emprunt public des prélèvements sur les
salaires des fonctionnaires et une
loterie dédié aux barrages une fois
achevé le barrage constituerait la plus
grande installation hydroélectrique en
afrique est le septième au monde d'une
capacité de 6000 mégawatts il boosterait
l'électrification du pays où la majorité
de la population vit sans électricité
plus encore l'ethiopie pourrait exporter
l'électricité chez ses voisins générant
ainsi des centaines de millions de
dollars de profits par an côté
agriculture la centrale hydro électrique
permettrait à 40 % des agriculteurs
éthiopien d'augmenter le rendement de
leurs terres du point de vue
géopolitique le barrage serait un atout
de taille car le contrôle sur le débit
du nil serait une véritable épine dans
le pied du caire qui en dépend
entièrement cet état de chose n'arrange
pas du tout les nouvelles autorités
égyptiennes qui menace plusieurs fois
l'ethiopie de guerre
pourtant suite à l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'abhisit fattah al-sisi le dialogue
politique s'amorce entre l'egypte le
soudan et l'ethiopie
en 2015 une avancée de taille addis
abeba s'engage à ne pas nuire à
l'environnement et aux intérêts
économiques des états riverains
c'est ici que le progrès cette place à
la stagnation
aucun des trois acteurs n'entend faire
des concessions sur les sujets au coeur
du débat
durée du remplissage du réservoir
assurance d'un débit minimum mécanisme
du règlement des différends ou celui du
partage de l'information ni la médiation
des etats-unis et de la banque mondiale
ni celle de l'union africaine n'arrive
pas à faire avancer le dialogue
dès lors la situation reste dans
l'impasse
l'impasse actuelle autour du barrage est
aggravée par une autre crise qui oppose
les acteurs sur le terrain depuis fin
2020 à l'ethiopie et le soudan
s'affrontent sur leur frontière commune
au coeur du contentieux la zone d'el
fahs shag à environ 250 kilomètres
carrés cette zone fait partie intégrante
du soudan mais elle est historiquement
peuplé par des fermiers éthiopiens les
deux pays maintenait le statu quo sur la
question de l'appartenance de ces
territoires
les tensions montent d'un cran en
décembre dernier le soudan accuse les
milices et l'armée éthiopienne
d'attaquer ses soldats dans la région
khartoum play lance alors une opération
militaire pour reprendre le contrôle sur
elles fâchent haga l'ethiopie mobilise
elle aussi les forces l'artillerie et
l'aviation seraient engagées des deux
côtés
les affrontements se poursuivent
toujours quelle est la raison de ce
regain de tension en effet depuis
novembre 2020 l'ethiopie fait face à un
conflit civil à l'intérieur du pays dans
la région de tigray addis abeba accuse
le soudan d'en profiter pour s'emparer
des terres éthiopienne en plus de ça
selon l'ethiopie c'est l'egypte qui
serait le principal instigateur de ce
conflit
la tentative égyptienne actuelle de
guerre par procuration contre l'ethiopie
via l'invasion soudanaise nous rappelle
la guerre par procuration similaire mené
en 1974 par siad barre depuis la somalie
étonnamment le flp t a servi de
principal agent de l'egypte dans ses
deux tentatives de guerre le soudan
réfute exercé l'influencé d'un
quelconque acteurs étrangers dans le
conflit frontalier
cependant en effet ces derniers mois
khartoum et le caire renforce activement
leur coopération militaire
le 1er novembre les chefs d'états majors
des deux pays se rencontrent à khartoum
ils s'engagent à intensifier les
contacts militaires en vue d'établir un
partenariat stratégique
quinze jours après l'armée égyptienne
entame des exercices communs avec les
forces soudanaises
une première depuis 2000 18 et le 20
décembre khartoum et le caire signent un
accord de coopération dans la production
d'armement sans surprise dans le conflit
frontalier soudano éthiopien l'egypte
choisi de soutenir le soudan l'egypte au
regard de ces développements dangereux
sur le terrain avec la plus grande
préoccupation et soulignent le besoin de
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour garantir que des incidents pareil
contre le soudan ne se reproduiront pas
à l'avenir
le front commun du caire et de khartoum
se profile donc face à addis abeba à 2
l'egypte et le soudan pourront-ils faire
plier l'ethiopie sur la question du
barrage il ya un an le caire a déjà
tenté le coup mais a échoué
et cela malgré l'appui des états unis en
octobre 2019 la maison blanche se
propose en médiateur dans la dispute
autour de ce barrage elle répond à la
demande de l'egypte proche allié
diplomatique et militaire
les négociations parrainées par
washington est la banque mondiale dure
quatre mois des négociations qui
aboutissent presse à un accord sauf
qu'au dernier moment les tupi refuse de
le signer et boycottent les réunions
la raison aux yeux de l'ethiopie
washington prend une position engagé
nous voulons que les américains jouent
un rôle constructif tout autre rôle est
inacceptable si les américains exercent
des pressions
cela doit être sur toutes les parties
pas seulement sur nous la diplomatie
américaine échoue malgré l'absence de
compromis en juillet 2020 addis abeba
commencent à remplir les réservoirs de
son barrage face à cela à washington
abandonne la neutralité s'engage
clairement auprès du caire début
septembre la maison blanche
oups on aide annuelle à l'ethiopie et de
quelque 130 millions de dollars selon
frei policy la cause cité la décision
unilatérale d'addis-abeba d'entamer le
remplissage du barrage et le mois
suivant donald trump dit tout haut ce
que l'égypte pensent tout bas
la situation est très dangereuse car
l'egypte ne pourra pas vivre comme ça
ils finiront par faire exploser le
barrage et je le dis haut et fort ils
vont faire exploser ce barrage en
ethiopie les menaces suscite la défiance
mais ne change rien à son comportement
dès juillet un autre dialogue est en
cours sous l'égide de l'union africaine
or six mois après son début le processus
est au point mort plusieurs états sont
prêts à prendre le relais de médiateur
l'initiative la plus récente vient des
émirats arabes unis selon lagence
soudanaise suna le 12 janvier une
délégation diplomatique émirati se rend
à khartoum et rencontre les ministres
soudanais nouvel échec en même temps la
russie se tient elle aussi prête à faire
bouger les lignes
un certain succès a été déjà marqué
auparavant en octobre 2019 au moment où
les tensions entre l'egypte et
l'ethiopie était alors un projet c'est
la rencontre organisée par le kremlin
qui a permis le retour au dialogue selon
le soudan il y a aussi d'autres
candidats pour parrainer le dialogue tel
que l'union européenne les nations unies
et les états unis
quoi qu'il en soit l'ethiopie compte
poursuivre les travaux du barrage à la
plus grande satisfaction de plusieurs de
ses voisins
car pour eux l'électricité exportée
pourrait être une véritable manne
selon les termes de l'accord trilatérale
de 2015
le soudan et l'egypte or on a un accès
prioritaire à cette énergie
amis d'autres clients il y a le kenya la
tanzanie le djibouti l'erythrée et le
rwanda la région a drastiquement besoin
d'électricité pour développer
l'industrie et booster la croissance
économique et l'énergie hydraulique
éthiopienne est propre et bon marché
à djibouti qui en portent déjà
l'électricité et tu apn coûte 5 fois
moins chère que celle qui est produite
localement
du coup les tropiques construit déjà
plusieurs nouvelles lignes électriques
vers les pays voisins en passe de
devenir un véritable hub énergétique des
bénéfices qui ne séduisent pourtant pas
l'egypte et le soudan
ce blocage est il insurmontable pour y
voir plus clair nous revenons vers
francs galante professionnels du secteur
de l'eau et est chercheur associé à la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
mais je galant pensez vous qu'un conflit
militaire entre l'egypte et l'ethiopie
soit possible à cause de ce barrage
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur une logique
de conflit armé et il faut tout faire
pour l'éviter mais si aucune solution
n'est trouvée je crains que les choses
s'enveniment très sérieusement alors par
contre on est rentrés d'ores et déjà
dans une guerre informationnelle une
guerre informationnelle de part et
d'autre entre l'éthiopie d'un côté
soudan egypte de l'autre et on voit
toute l'importance des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui qu'ils rentrent dans la
danse si je puis dire avec effectivement
des influenceurs issus de la société
civile ou proches des gouvernements qui
attise un peu la querelle des
populations à saveur à savoir par par un
certain nombre de hashtag par exemple
neil fort et egypte ni rights côté côté
égyptien
et puis vous avez l'utilisation de
réseaux sociaux tels que tik tok par
exemple qui met en scène une jeune
éthiopienne
se mettant à danser pour distraire les
égyptiens pendant que nous remplissons
le barrage donc déjà en 2012 vous aviez
une diplomatie un peu du muscle par voie
informationnel ça continue aujourd'hui
et il faut véritablement espérer qu'on
passe pas une femme plus sérieuse qui
selon vous est le meilleur candidat
aujourd'hui pour parrainer les
négociations entre les parties c'est la
russie ce sont les états unis roues bien
les voisins alors la russie peut très
clairement joué son rôle
on se souvient du sommet russie afrique
à sotchi
il ya plus d'un an où le président de
poutine a été approché par par l'egypte
notamment par l'ethiopie pour essayer de
s'impliquer sur le sujet on a vu
l'intervention américaine sous trump est
l'intervention la banque mondiale avec
david malpas qui s'est impliqué sur le
sujet à partir de novembre 2019
moi je pense très sérieusement que un
acteur dont on parle relativement peu un
très très grand rôle à jouer c'est la
chine la chine et est un partenaire
stratégique de l'ethiopie et d'un autre
côté la chine est également très proche
de l'egypte donc on voit très bien le
rôle que pourrait jouer
l'egypte avec la chine et la chine avec
l'ethiopie mais je pense qu'il ya
également potentiellement deux autres
deux autres pays qui peuvent jouer ce
rôle
les émirats arabes unis très impliqué en
ethiopie également l'arabie saoudite et
émirats arabes unis et l'arabie saoudite
sont également très proche de l'egypte
donc voilà je je je crois très
sincèrement qu'il faut aujourd'hui
essayer toutes les voies possibles
eh bien on va sans doute rentrer sur une
mauvaise passe d'implication
diplomatique
hydro diplomatique j'allais dire et
c'est tant mieux parce qu'il faut
absolument éviter que les armes ne parle
merci beaucoup monsieur gala en jeu
rappelle franck galland professionnels
hector de l'eau et chercheur associé à
la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique était là aujourd'hui avec
nous merci pour votre analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]